well my name is dr service i am the CEO
of the electronic exchange of argentina
and the the most important question for
me was the following what was the most
interesting idea
i heard today one for me in my opinion
my humble opinion was pronounced by the
ministry of chile mister somerville
about including the concept of happiness
and predictability in the life that's
very important in social security
problems because one important thing in
in the brain of the people in the mind
of the people is to be happy and have
dreams of the future in that concept the
government's through the social policy
is very important to reintroduce that
concept for me it was a great point to
be considered and of course to be
discussed